I've experienced constipation after finishing an Eastern protocol and starting my new
RIFE program.
Magnesium citrate and vitamin C crystals have helped, but also I've gotten kidney stone
pains.
The RIFE helps get rid of pains, though.
So let's stop there a second.
So, if a person has constipation, one therapy to use is magnesium with vitamin C.
And the reason is is that magnesium, if you take excess magnesium, you will dump that
magnesium back into the colon.
Magnesium, be it an iodide, will then draw water and it will help loosen your stools and
you'll have better bowel movements.
But a person with kidney stones is trying to be careful of excess mineral consumption,
so they don't want to necessarily be doing magnesium.
And somebody even a cancer protocol doesn't necessarily want to be taking vitamin C because
you're trying to stay away from antioxidants if you're doing an oxidative therapy.
So what do you do?
Let's finish this question.
I received my protocol from you today and we'll start it tomorrow.
Will this help with my bowel movements or should I try some of the other things in my
binder?
The animals work, but I would have to do them almost daily to help with bowel movements.
So I don't know.
I doubt that I have gave you anything in your protocol, if you're having constipation issues.
Now taking a digestive enzyme that may very well might be in your protocol, it would
be probably called clear digest, that could very well help with bowel movements.
So why does a person get constipation?
Well there's multiple reasons.
First of you constipation because they're not eating enough fiber, they can be constipated.
First of you constipation because they just have a lot of inflammation in their gut.
It constipation because they have a weakness of parasitic waves.
The parasitic waves are the constriction of the muscles around the gut to help you move
your feces through the bowel.
And what controls parasitosis is the vagal nerve.
So it's the, it's crazy nerve 10, the vagus nerve.
The vagal nerve is your parasympathetic nervous system.
So doing coffee enemas, it can help with constipation two ways, that physical liquid in your
colon can soften things up in your lower part of the colon and your descending colon particularly
in the sigmoid colon.
And it can help move things through.
But the other thing is that coffee enemas will stimulate the vagal nerve down at the rectal
area, the vagal nerve, cranial nerve 10 stimulates the parasympathetics which is going
to stimulate parasitosis.
You can do other things that should be in your binder that talk about help with constipation.
The easiest thing, the cheapest and the simplest is a product that we privately labeled phase
six assist.
It's, it's a super aloe product which is a specific type of aloe that will help loosen
your bowels.
So aloe vera, you think of as, you know, really good for your gut.
So what is aloe vera?
It's from a aloe plant.
It could help heal your intestinal tract.
It could help heal your skin.
It's really good for birds, et cetera.
But there's a whole bunch of different varieties of aloe.
The aloe that we're talking about for your gut is a type of aloe called cape aloe.
So that's not necessarily healing your intestinal tract, but it's, it's a great tool for loosening
your bowel.
Now a person could use set a tee, set it as an herb that will help with constipation, but I
don't like long-term use of that because it can cause issues on your gut wall.
So it can be hard on your gut wall.
Set a tee also stimulates parasitic waves and it can cause cramping and you can just feel
like, oh, my stomach is just killing me.
So I'm not a super big fan of set up.
There's another herb called cascara sagrada.
That's a good herb to help with bowel movements, but that can be hard on your bowel long-term too.
It's much less expensive and easier to use cape aloe because it's pretty cheap.
And cape aloe, it's, you know, we have one that's made by
ortho molecular, we private label it, you might get an ortho molecular label.
Super aloe, they make it in two forms, they make the 250 milligram and 450 milligram.
We have another product that has only 50 milligrams of cape aloe in it, but if a person has constipation
issues, you should get one of the larger ones.
Typically if you take one, if you're like really bad constipation issues, if you try and take
two in the evening, you don't need to take me easy with it, you take two in the evening,
you're going to have bowel movements next day, probably multiple.
And you might go, well that was too much, I went like six times today.
So maybe you'll take one in the evening.
We have people that are on two or those, we have some people that are on an auto ship of
the super aloe 450 and I don't know, they have serious constipation issues that, you know,
they maybe they need to eat more fiber too.
But will the protocol that you're on help with the constipation, maybe, maybe not?
It's a good idea to have some of that cape aloe in your, in your cupboard.
My wife and I have to have the cape aloe in our cupboard and, you know, you don't have
to use it once in a while, but if you eat something that is very constipated, you feel like
you got new or regular, usually because you ate something that was inflammatory to
your gut that you shouldn't have any eating, then getting it out of the skin, it's taking
some cape aloe can be good.
Anytime it's people that are eating something, a food that they're sensitive to, that is actually
a cause of constipation.
So figuring that out and dealing with that can be beneficial as well.